th
[音楽]
ローソンの直線をつくりましたあの滑りたいじゃね
動画と気味ではなく滑りたくて人間に滑ってもかなりため滑ると思うんですけども前何
を伝え滑れば一番ローションの上で滑るのかっていうのとん田継承していきたいと思い
ますなぜ意見人間でこのローションの様子ベルト何年くらいすれどうーその後いろんな
ものを試してみてやなぜの道具とかねものを使った時にローションの上で1マス分の顔
ちょっと今日は検証していきたいと思いますでは行こう
[音楽]
助走をつけてから行くのでここがスタブすごくスタートにして過ごしてからスタート
です
後からスタートしてどこまで滑れるか違ってみようと思います
僕は多分30m に行くんじゃないかと思っています
ni
つい
わーん
さあどうだ
7メーターでそのもいけるって言っていて a
1砂糖
ええええええ
[音楽]
ああああああ
20分
一つ結果17メートル70センチです
ペンまあまあじゃない結構ずその動きやは人間の記録で17メーターちょいだったんで
次はこんなものを使ってこの日6を超えるかどうかちょっと検証していきたいとおもい
ます
季節的にそれが売ってなかっでそれっぽいものをホームセンターで買ってきました
それを止められたんですよねそれで助走をつけて取り込んで中に入って来伸ばされて
いく
ええええええ
じゃーん
[拍手]
ん
キュアでございますひざおいてちょうどベストな価格でいきそうなのでちょっと足に
弾いてくるも全て見ると思います持って走って書くと祈ったのか食べてるんだだ
ああああああ
どうぞ
[音楽]
以下3名た自生地ですせ
あるよこれ
あっ剥がさぞ
[音楽]
をもうちょっとこういう感じになっちゃ
tan
tee
知ったけどへ連れられないもんだってフォロワー
それでやってみる通りだよやって見事ににあるってあったん
ああああああ
バーン
愛知
スタートん
[音楽]
はぁんっ
h
どうぞ
ああああああ
ううううううっ
[音楽]
山
ねぇ
ベイツどうぞ
[音楽]
うんん
結果ファー
いじめたサンジて実写
[音楽]
me
uh
うううう
me
バッハ
ああああああああああああ